être déficient visuel n'empêche pas de
se divertir en assistant à un spectacle
les éducateurs du centre de la ressource
accompagne les adolescents déficients
visuels au tempo festival à saint leu
les spectacles ont été choisis en amont
pour qu'ils puissent comprendre au mieux
ce qui se passe mais d'abord à nous de
comprendre un peu la façon dont ils
perçoivent les choses
on commence par une exposition de
super-héros pays
c'est pas trop c'est bizarre les
oreilles les yeux
c'est ce que ses yeux donc voilà je n'ai
qui sont ici ce qui serait là mais c'est
quoi au fait
ouais il a dit d'accord une fois que ça
c'est bien c'est être là avec le tout
les différentes mais différentes
matières parce que voilà ça me permet
quand même de de nous représenter ces
choses là
pourquoi c'est la différence des
tableaux en fait à peu près on va je
sais pas trop de quoi il s'agit mais
j'arrive quand même à tuer voilà avoir
peu près ce que c'est les déficients
visuels peuvent se représenter
mentalement une couleur une forme un
spectacle
il faut pour cela un contact
sensorielles ou une explication le temps
du spectacle les éducateurs se font les
yeux des adolescents étaient bien parce
que voilà ça a parlé c'était une thèse
au théâtre et en plus il y avait les
acrobaties sur les lots et
jessica capote et moi même expliqué l
m'expliquer ce qui se passait et tout
est un plus qu'assez map assez drôle
avec voilà une femme qui veut se marier
mais qui n'a pas de mari et qui ont
choisi un d'un kubrick enfin voilà
qu'est ce que j'ai pensé c'est
divertissant
comment je fais moi j'analyse la traîne
et ils vont passer une autre scène que
moi je suis encore en train d'analyser
la semaine précédente et quand on a
lisant la scène qu'ils font là je vais
comprendre le détail d'avant et voilà là
cela je vais le comprendre on est un peu
les yeux de la personne mais en fait on
a une représentation on essaie de se
représenter ce qu'elle ne voit pas il
veut donner une image en fait les
personnes se sentent déficientes
visuelles ont besoin en fait des
explications lui propose une commune
audiodescription on va lui dire ce que
nous on voit ils peuvent pour qu'elles
puissent se représenter un spectacle
cette sortie fait partie d'un projet
global proposé par le centre de la
ressource
ils suivent les jeunes déficients
sensoriels et les accompagne vers la
plus grande autonomie possible surtout
au niveau
visuel dont qui perdent toute leur
autonomie donc avec cette équipe
vraiment pluridisciplinaires ont leur
apportent chacun des éléments et des
techniques pour pour arriver à être
autonome et et pouvoir avoir un projet
de vie
faire des études une autonomie au niveau
au niveau pédagogique c'est un peu grâce
à lui que j'ai appris j'ai appris le
braille quand j'étais petit
après - quand même suivi leur scolarité
jusqu'à maintenant d'ailleurs voilà ce
que j'ai quand même plus de confiance en
moi
voilà je suis un peu je suis en voyant
tu vois c'est pas forcément facile de
liévin c'était combien de temps que tu
es suivi par le centre sava fait un 9 10
ans on a fini 117 portée pour beaucoup
de choses par exemple à l'école ça m'a
permis d'avoir plus de matériel de
faciliter un temps plus pour mes devoirs
c
non c'est plus facile maintenant avec la
résistance se balader flâner au milieu
du festival avec d'autres jeunes
partager ce moment
cela fait aussi partie du projet
important leur proposer ça c'est vrai
que souvent ils ont tendance à s'isoler
à avoir peur de la foule donc on est
vraiment là pour les accompagner les
aider à faire face à ce genre situation
est appréciée aussi malgré leur handicap
à être entouré de et apprécier un
spectacle jeune c'est un une bonne
ambiance
le soleil se couche sur le festival
l'équipe de la ressource assistent à un
dernier spectacle avant de raccompagner
chacun des jeunes vers leur domicile
ils seront gardés en mémoire cette
journée remplie d'applaudissements